Profª. Tamar Gendler: A aula de hoje
é sobre a alegação que
temos explorado,
no contexto da ética de Aristóteles,
de que a maneira de cultivar a virtude
é cultivando certos tipos de
hábitos em nós mesmos.
E eu quero começar mostrando uma
imagem de uma camiseta,
que era popular no MIT em
meados dos anos 1990,
quando o meu marido era um
estudante de pós-graduação lá.
E a camiseta dizia o seguinte...
"Gravidade: Não é apenas uma
boa ideia, é a lei."
Se vocês tivessem sido alunos do MIT,
você estariam rolando de rir.
[risos]
Tal como é, seres sociais que vocês
são, vocês estão rolando de rir
pensando que outros seres
rolam de rir com isto.
[risos]
Mas o mais interessante nesta camiseta
é que ela traz uma distinção
entre 2 tipos de leis.
Porque a gravidade não é uma lei
que diz como você deve se comportar.
É uma lei que diz como as
coisas se comportam.
E os filósofos fazem uma
distinção entre 2 tipos de leis.
Por um lado, existem as leis
normativas, deveres,
coisas que indicam como você
deve fazer as coisas,
as coisas que expressam, como o
nome indica, as normas.
Essas são coisas como:
"Olhe para os 2 lados antes
de atravessar a rua."
Isso é algo que você deve fazer.
Não seria engraçado ter
uma camiseta dizendo:
"Olhe para os 2 lados antes
de atravessar a rua:
Não é apenas uma boa ideia, é a lei."
Certo?
Poderia ser a lei... e a camiseta,
por muitas razões, não
seria engraçada.
Não seria engraçado ter
uma camiseta dizendo:
"Não coma na biblioteca: Não é
apenas uma boa ideia, é a lei."
Porque poderia ser uma lei não
comer na biblioteca.
E não seria engraçado ter
uma camiseta dizendo:
"100 km/h: Não é apenas uma
boa ideia, é a lei"...
porque, na verdade, é
uma lei normativa.
As leis normativas expressam
juízos sumativos
sobre o modo como as
coisas deveriam ser.
São leis, no sentido que
você as encontra
na Faculdade de Direito de Yale.
Mas existem leis de um tipo
muito diferente,
espalhadas por todo o campi.
Espalhadas, na verdade,
por todos os lados.
E essas são as leis descritivas.
Elas dizem a forma como as
coisas realmente são.
Talvez fosse engraçado
ter uma camiseta:
"Se um carro bate em você,
você vai morrer.
Não é apenas uma coisa
ruim, é a lei."
Porque "Se um carro bate em
você, você vai morrer"
é uma descrição de como é o mundo.
É um fato sobre o mundo que
se trata de uma lei
no sentido de que ela permite que
você faça previsões
sobre o futuro com base no passado.
Ela fala sobre as relações legiformes
entre as coisas no passado e
as coisas no futuro.
Da mesma forma, é uma lei da
biologia-química-física, basicamente,
que "as migalhas causam
apodrecimento do livro".
Essa é uma descrição de um
fato sobre o mundo
que pode corresponder com a lei
normativa "não coma na biblioteca".
Mas elas não deixam de ser
alegações muito diferentes.
E, finalmente, ao passo que há um
limite de velocidade no seu carro
estipulado em 100km/h, há um
limite de velocidade em tudo
que não supera os 300 km/s.
A velocidade da luz expressa
uma lei descritiva
sobre o quão rápido é possível ir,
ao passo que o limite de
velocidade "100 km/h"
expressa uma lei normativa sobre o
quão rápido você pode ir.
Agora, por que eu comecei esta aula
sobre Aristóteles e o hábito
com um monte de comentários
sobre a diferença
entre leis normativas e descritivas?
A razão é esta: Os
hábitos são ferramentas
para transformar deveres em fazeres.
Os hábitos são formas de pegar
os compromissos normativos
que temos sobre como queremos
que as coisas sejam
e utilizar o fato de que somos
seres psicológicos,
biológicos, químicos, físicos
nos quais os padrões
de relações legiformes
descritivas podem ser criadas
através da repetição das mesmas
atividades mais e mais.
Assim, quando Aristóteles diz
que nós aprendemos um ofício ao
produzir o mesmo produto
que devemos produzir quando o
tivermos aprendido;
que nos tornamos construtores
construindo, harpistas tocando harpa,
da mesma forma que nos tornamos
justos praticando atos justas,
temperantes praticando atos temperantes,
corajosos praticando
ações corajosas...
ele está explicando a utilidade
de reconhecer a conexão
entre as leis normativas (como
pensamos o que queremos ser)
e as leis descritivas (como
naturalmente vamos nos moldando).
Lembrem-se que ao descrever
como é que podemos cultivar as
virtudes, ele contrasta isso
com 2 casos em que se aplicam as
leis meramente descritivas.
Ele disse que não é como tentar
treinar que uma pedra fique no ar,
porque esse é um caso em que se
aplica uma lei descritiva.
Nem é o caso de assistir a
uma planta desabrochar
ao fornecê-la água e luz,
porque, mais uma vez,
é um caso em que se aplicam as
leis meramente descritivas.
O interessante sobre o reino do meio
enfocado em quase todo o Ética a
Nicômaco é que se trata
do domínio onde transita o princípio
que eu acabei de articular.
É o domínio onde é
possível pensar sobre
como nós queremos que as coisas sejam,
a agir como se as coisas já
estivessem assim e, sob
uma conduta de autorrealização, para
que as coisas se tornem assim.
A percepção básica de
Aristóteles é que,
se você quer se tornar alguma coisa,
aja como se você já fosse isso.
Se você deseja se tornar
instintivamente corajoso,
atue como um corajoso.
E então isso vai se tornar
natural em você.
Se você quer se tornar um pianista,
treine os dedos para atuar como
os dedos de um pianista.
Você aprende a arte de tocar
piano produzindo o produto
que você deve produzir quando você
tiver aprendido a tocar piano.
Ou seja, você aprende a se tornar um
pianista praticando o piano.
Portanto, os padrões de
comportamento que estão
inicialmente
sob controle consciente podem,
a partir de um processo de prática
repetida, tornarem-se automatizados.
No início, quando você
aprendeu a dirigir um carro,
você tinha de pensar com cuidado
o que fazer com cada um dos pés
e cada uma das mãos.
Qualquer um de vocês que fez
aula de dança sabe que
quando você aprende a dançar, você
começa por contagem: "1 e 2...".
Eu não vou dançar aqui, porque
isso vai para a internet...
[risos]
Mas aqueles que aprenderam a dançar
sabem que o comportamento que
esteve inicialmente
sob controle consciente se
tornou automatizado,
de modo que aqueles que foram
treinados para dançar valsa e tango
vão experimentar agora, ao
ouvir a música,
um tipo de passo motorizado
ativado nos seus pés.
O fato de isso ocorrer inevitavelmente
com os seres biológicos como
nós nos dá uma ferramenta
para transformar compromissos
normativos em leis descritivas.
Portanto, se tornou o caso de,
embora tenha começado
como uma norma, "olhe para os 2 lados
antes de atravessar a rua"
agora é uma descrição de mim:
eu olho para os 2 lados antes
de atravessar a rua.
E qualquer um de vocês que já foi
para a Inglaterra ou Austrália
– onde as pessoas dirigem do lado
esquerdo ao invés do direito –
sabe o quanto é difícil superar
esse hábito arraigado.
Na verdade, quando estou na Inglaterra,
eu olho para ambos os
lados umas 30 vezes,
porque eu estou muito desorientada
pelo fato de que a minha rotina
não se encaixa nessa situação.
Se você cresceu dirigindo
um carro com marcha
ou um carro automático e tem
de mudar para o outro,
é incrivelmente difícil
fazer as alterações.
Quando nos tornamos habituados a um
certo padrão de comportamento,
algo que era inicialmente uma regra
normativa se torna algo descritivo.
De fato, um dos principais
objetivos na criação dos filhos
é incutir neles respostas instintivas
que esteja em harmonia com os
compromissos reflexivos.
Eu quero que ao receber um item, sem
reflexão, automaticamente,
meus filhos digam: "Obrigado".
Agora, a mesma capacidade que
nos permite transformar
os compromissos normativos
endossados reflexivamente
em práticas habituais pode ser
implementada, de forma natural,
no reforço dos hábitos que
desejamos nos livrar.
Para muitos de nós, assim que
abrimos o computador,
existe uma compulsão imediata
para abrir a internet
e uma compulsão imediata para
checar a página do Facebook.
Nós já falamos na 1ª aula sobre
uma das formas de lidar
com isso: eliminando a conexão
que leva você até a
página do Facebook.
Se você desligar o seu
navegador de internet,
então não importa o quão
instintiva é a ação,
você não será capaz de
responder à compulsão.
Se você tem uma tendência
instintiva de assaltar a geladeira
à meia-noite para beber o leite
achocolatado que está lá,
se você jogar o leite fora, então
você não tem de mudar o hábito.
Portanto, uma das estratégias
de autorregulação
envolve limitar o acesso à resposta
que você deseja se livrar.
Mas, às vezes, a resposta que
queremos nos livrar
não é algo que queremos
eliminar completamente.
Certo? Eu não quero me livrar de
toda a comida da minha cozinha.
Alguns de vocês não querem se livrar
do acesso à internet no computador.
Portanto, o que vamos
considerar na aula de hoje
são as estratégias adicionais
disponíveis para quebrar o vínculo
entre os hábitos indesejados, ou o
vínculo entre os indícios
e os hábitos indesejados
originados por eles.
Eu quero pedir para vocês
pegarem os seus clickers.
Estas são as únicas vezes que
vamos usar os clickers hoje,
mas prometo que nas próximas aulas os
usaremos em mais ocasiões.
Então, a pergunta é: O que
é verdade em você?
Que você não tem comportamentos
habituais que gostaria de mudar?
Tudo em você é perfeito?
Você é como a figura do capítulo
de abertura de Alan Kazdin
que quer mudar todas as
pessoas no mundo,
mas que não precisa mudar
nada em você mesmo?
Ou você tem pelo menos um
comportamento habitual
que gostaria de mudar?
E a votação será encerrada
em 6, 5, 4, 3, 2...
Temos 110 respostas
e vamos ver como elas são.
OK. 8% de vocês são perfeitos.
Estou emocionada.
Eu sempre quis ter uma turma
cheia de gente perfeita.
Pelo menos eu tenho,
eu acho que é aquele lado
esquerdo ao fundo.
Mas 92% de vocês têm pelo menos um
hábito que gostaria de mudar.
Para 92% que têm esse hábito
que gostaria de mudar,
uma 2ª pergunta.
Para qualquer um que já tenha
se livrado de um hábito
de forma consciente, o que
é verdade em você?
Você foi capaz de mudar esse
comportamento habitual
apenas dizendo: "Quer saber?
Eu não vou mais checar a
internet na sala de aula."
"Quer saber? Eu vou
praticar o meu violino
todos os dias às 10h."
"Quer saber? Eu vou fazer a
minha cama pela manhã."
Então, quantos foram capazes de
mudar o comportamento habitual
apenas renunciando a ele e
quantos não foram capazes
de mudar esse comportamento habitual?
E, novamente, vamos dar 10 segundos...
OK. Vamos ver os números que saem.
4, 3, 2, 1...
OK. Oh, meu Deus!
35% de vocês puderam abdicar dos
comportamentos habituais.
Mas os outros 65% são seres
humanos de carne e osso do tipo
que me fizeram dar uma
conferência nesta classe.
OK. É muito frequente o caso
– embora, obviamente, não
seja sempre assim –
em que é extraordinariamente difícil
simplesmente tentar renunciar
a um comportamento indesejado.
E o capítulo que lemos de Jonathan
Haidt e, na verdade, as leituras
que estamos fazendo durante o
semestre, explica por que é assim.
Parte da explicação que 65% de vocês
estão na categoria de pessoas
incapazes de abdicar de um
comportamento indesejado
é que não estamos apenas
compostos de razão.
Platão nos deu a metáfora da
razão, espírito e apetite.
Haidt nos dá a metáfora do
ginete e do elefante.
Cada um dos autores lidos
até agora falou sobre
as maneiras pelas quais estamos
processando fundamentalmente
informações num nível racional,
que pode ou não alcançar
os outros aspectos do que
Platão chama de alma.
Portanto, Aristóteles, naquelas
incríveis 5 páginas de encerramento
de Ética a Nicômaco, a última
parte do último livro,
escreve o seguinte: "Se os
argumentos bastassem em si mesmos
para tornar os homens bons,
eles teriam feito jus a grandes
recompensas e [...] não faltariam.
Mas ele destaca que, na
grande maioria dos casos,
simplesmente dizer às pessoas: "Ei,
quer saber? Você provavelmente
deve pagar os seus impostos em
algum momento na primavera"...
não as leva a agir em
consonância com o que elas
querem,
ou você quer, que seja feito.
Os argumentos solitários, apelos
solitários à racionalidade,
funcionam em casos pontuais.
Mas isso não funciona o tempo todo.
Bom, porque a maior parte
do material lido abarca os
autores antigos,
quero salientar que os textos seguintes
– os textos que eu estou
pulando em 1.179 anos –,
é na verdade uma expressão
de algo que transcorre
em cada um dos textos antigos
gregos que temos abordado...
a expressão de um certo tipo
de elitismo cultural
sobre a diferença entre o
bem-nascido e a massa restante.
Mas eu quero deixar de lado o que é,
penso eu, um motivo legítimo
para desafiar algumas das
coisas que Aristóteles diz
e se concentrar no que eu acho
verdade sobre o que ele mencionou,
ou seja, que é impossível
mudar, pelo argumento,
o que tem sido absorvido como o
resultado dos hábitos de alguém.
E Aristóteles discorre
sobre algo que vamos falar daqui a
mais ou menos 5 semanas.
Ou seja, a partir desse fato
sobre os seres humanos,
que a experiência precoce molda o
comportamento subsequente,
e que executar regulações pode moldar
o comportamento de uma
forma pró-social,
parecem existir implicações
no modo como as sociedades
devem ser estruturadas.
E quando chegarmos à unidade
de filosofia política,
veremos mais uma vez essas páginas
finais do Ética a Nicômaco.
O que eu quero salientar agora é que aí
está uma ligação extraordinária
entre o que Aristóteles está
dizendo neste texto antigo...
aqui está uma bela edição do
Ética em latim do século 15,
aqui está a tradução que
estamos usando...
e me parece, e eis o que eu quero fazer
no restante da aula de hoje,
que a percepção fundamental da
ética de Aristóteles
é o que está por trás da literatura, num
certo tipo de prática terapêutica
– a terapia
cognitivo-comportamental... e eu quero
mostrar a vocês
como isso se desenrola num tipo
particular de livro de autoajuda.
Em particular, um guia de parentalidade.
A alegação que eu quero fazer é
basicamente que o Ética a Nicômaco
de Aristóteles é o maior guia de
parentalidade já escrito.
Portanto, quem procurava um presente
para o sobrinho
recém-nascido, acaba de
encontrar!
[risos]
O que eu quero fazer é contextualizar a
terapia cognitivo-comportamental,
começando com uma discussão sobre
a literatura dos animais
da qual ela faz parte.
A terapia comportamental explora o fato
de que somos seres evoluídos,
contínuos aos animais
não-humanos, nos tipos de
controle sobre o comportamento que
estão disponíveis para nós.
Com as minhas desculpas para aqueles
que já tiveram Psych 110,
eis uma breve introdução sobre o
condicionamento pavloviano.
Oh! Perdão.
Esqueçam as desculpas... mais algumas
citações de Aristóteles.
Como diz Aristóteles: "Nós
aprendemos um ofício ao produzir
o mesmo produto que devemos produzir
quando tivermos aprendido.
Nós nos tornamos construtores
construindo, harpistas tocando harpa".
Quando Aristóteles diz isso, ele
destaca a importância de estruturar
a sua experiência de tal modo que
você tenha a oportunidade
de realizar o comportamento
que se deseja cultivar.
Dê a si mesmo a chance de fazer
as coisas que você quer
que se tornem habituais e essas
coisas se tornarão habituais.
Tudo bem. Aqui está o cachorro.
Imagino que a maioria de vocês
saiba, mas vale a pena rever,
existe uma técnica de regulação
do comportamento animal
conhecida há milhares de anos.
Temos relatos do treinamento
de animais domésticos
na antiga tradição grega e,
de fato, Descartes
tem uma longa discussão sobre como é
possível treinar os cães.
(Descartes tinha uma visão
idiossincrática sobre os animais.
Ele pensava que eram máquinas.
Mas em relação a essa hipótese,
a suposição equivocada
não faz diferença.)
As obras clássicas de
condicionamento trabalham
com o antes de o condicionamento
ocorrer; você identifica um item
– digamos, a comida – que
produz na criatura uma resposta
de salivação, nesse caso,
ou de excitação.
Assim, o cachorro vê a
comida e vai: "uau!".
A comida, nesse caso, é o que
os psicólogos chamam
de estímulo não-condicionado.
É algo que, sem a nossa
intervenção, produz na criatura
que você está tentando condicionar
uma resposta incondicionada.
Você mostra a comida e,
sem qualquer intervenção da
nossa parte, o cão saliva.
Por outro lado, há muitas coisas
– campainhas, por exemplo –
que não produzem nenhuma
reação no cachorro.
Você toca uma campainha.
O cachorro diz: "Grande coisa. Quem se
importa? É uma campainha".
Então, nesse caso, você apresenta o
que se chama um estímulo neutro
e o que você obtém do cão é
chamado sem resposta.
Agora vem o condicionamento.
Você dá ao seu cachorro,
simultaneamente, a campainha e a
comida.
E a presença da comida é suficiente
para produzir nele o "Oh, uau!".
Certo? O cachorro diz:
"Comida! Salivar! Excelente!
Mmm! Algo para comer!"
O que você fez foi pegar estímulos
pareados – a campainha e a comida –
e produzir, como resultado da
introdução de estímulos pareados,
uma resposta incondicionada que
segue sendo, neste momento, u
ma resposta à comida.
Mas os animais são seres associativos.
E, eventualmente, esta resposta
incondicionada – o "Oh, uau!" –
que resulta como uma relação com
a introdução da comida
vem a ser pareada com o
estímulo neutro.
E quando isso ocorre,
quando a campainha produz no cachorro
a resposta de salivação,
chega-se, assim, ao
condicionamento do estímulo
para produzir no animal uma
resposta condicionada.
Mas esse tipo de coisa é possível
não só com os animais.
Nas páginas iniciais do
livro de Alan Kazdin,
ouvimos a história do
pobre bebê Albert
que costumava pensar que os coelhos
brancos eram inofensivos,
até que o estímulo neutro de um
coelho branco foi pareado
com o estímulo incondicionado de um
ruído alto, aterrorizando-o.
E quando isso ocorreu,
Albert passou a associar
o que anteriormente era
neutro, o coelho branco,
com um sentimento de medo.
Os seres humanos são capazes
de terem associações
com valência positiva ou
negativa; associações
que produzem neles respostas
emocionais positivas ou negativas.
E são capazes de ter
essas associações
com entidades que antes não
tinham nenhum valor para eles.
Então, com isso em mente,
os psicólogos começaram a
pensar de modo mais geral
sobre a relação entre
objetos e comportamentos,
e os resultados que esses
objetos ou comportamentos
estão associados.
Enquanto o condicionamento
clássico está preocupado
com o consumo passivo de
algum item do mundo
– o alimento é apresentado a você, um
coelho é apresentado a você,
e surge uma determinada
associação –,
o condicionamento operante está
preocupado com a relação
entre os comportamentos que
você mesmo executa
e os resultados normalmente
originados por eles.
Portanto, em nosso repertório
comportamental, há
um monte de coisas que fazemos que
são comportamentos desejados.
São comportamentos desejados: ler,
ir para a academia, ser educado
com os seus colegas,
ligar para os seus pais pelo
menos 1 vez por semana.
E também temos
comportamentos
indesejados.
Coisas que queríamos não fazer.
Os maus hábitos que 92% de
vocês nesta sala têm.
E o que os psicólogos observaram é
que temos recursos disponíveis
para usar os mecanismos
que o condicionamento fornece para
aumentar diferencialmente
vários tipos de comportamento.
Se estamos atentos às
consequências que os
comportamentos
normalmente dão origem, e se
interferirmos para controlá-las,
podemos aumentar a incidência de
certos tipos de comportamento
e diminuir a incidência
de outros tipos.
Portanto, se há um comportamento
desejado que você deseja ter mais,
você pode parear algum tipo de
reforço com esse comportamento,
como consequência.
Você pode parear com ele um
reforço positivo.
Eu posso reforçar os seus
esforços ao escrever um artigo
proporcionando o reforço positivo de
uma carta na sua transcrição
que tenha valor para os
futuros empregadores.
Eu posso proporcionar a você
o reforço positivo
para o comportamento desejado.
Ou é possível reforçar um
comportamento desejado
com o que é conhecido como
reforço negativo.
A remoção de um estímulo aversivo.
Se há barulho no quarto,
você está reforçando negativamente a
sua tendência a usar tampões
de ouvido, caso isso reduza a
consequência aversiva
de estar num quarto barulhento.
Podemos aumentar os
comportamentos que queremos
aumentar
associando a eles as consequências que
servem para aumentar o valor,
subjetivamente, que esse
comportamento tem para o
indivíduo,
pareando alguma coisa que o indivíduo
já gosta com o comportamento.
Além disso, podemos
diminuir a probabilidade
de um comportamento indesejado, ou
de um desejado, associando
esse comportamento com alguma
consequência negativa.
Podemos retirar algo que você gosta
se você agir de uma forma
que não queremos.
Nas 2 aulas antes ou logo
depois da pausa em março
falaremos sobre a punição e
como isso funciona aqui.
Então, os comportamentos podem ser
associados com efeitos positivos
ou podem ser associados com
efeitos negativos.
E, às vezes, isso
acontece naturalmente.
Quando eu como bolo de
chocolate, isso está associado
com a consequência positiva do
sabor que ele me dá.
Isso é reforçado de forma
positiva porque o comportamento,
comer o bolo, dá origem a uma
consequência natural, o sabor do bolo.
Mas pode não estar tão claro para mim
que o comportamento também
promove uma consequência
que eu não avalio tão positivamente.
Ele aumenta a quantidade de
obstrução arterial
no caminho até o meu coração.
Tornar evidente para as pessoas
quais são as consequências negativas
naturais de seus comportamentos
é uma das maneiras de fazer
uso desse paradigma.
Portanto, podemos pegar
comportamentos que queremos ter
mais
e associá-los a
consequências positivas.
Podemos pegar comportamentos
que queremos ter mais
e associá-los a
consequências negativas.
Podemos ajudar a
conscientizar as pessoas
sobre as consequências
positivas ou negativas
que esses comportamentos já possuem.
E, finalmente, podemos descobrir
que, sem nos darmos conta,
um certo tipo de reforço
é, na verdade,
a preservação de um comportamento
que queremos nos livrar.
Um pai pode descobrir que uma
criança continua chorando
porque o choro, um
comportamento indesejado,
está associado a um reforço:
a atenção dos pais.
E alguém poderia reconhecer que a
remoção desse reforço
reduzirá o comportamento.
Assim, nesse caso, o
condicionamento operante
pega a nossa capacidade de
associação e a usa de forma
familiar
para aumentar os
comportamentos desejados
e diminuir os
comportamentos
indesejados.
Mas, é claro, os
comportamentos não surgem do
nada.
E a 3ª coisa que o
condicionamento operante
trata são os antecedentes que deram
origem aos comportamentos.
Para um comportamento ocorrer ele
depende, antes de tudo, dos
eventos de ajuste.
Se o reforço está propenso de
aumentar a probabilidade
de ocorrer o comportamento.
Você estará mais suscetível a beber
leite achocolatado à noite
se você tiver fome.
Se você beber água 1
hora antes, então
o reforço de beber leite achocolatado
não será tão grande para você.
Você pode definir as condições
de modo a tornar os reforços
mais ou menos eficazes.
Você também pode oferecer
suportes a você mesmo
ou a outras pessoas.
Eu quero ajudá-lo com a leitura,
então eu forneço guias de
leitura que conduzem
às partes do texto que eu acho que
são as mais importantes e,
assim, reduzo as barreiras iniciais
que a leitura pode oferecer.
Eu dou suporte ao comportamento,
tornando a tarefa mais gerenciável.
E, finalmente, podemos dar
origem a um comportamento
diferencialmente pela
presença ou ausência
dos chamados estímulos
discriminativos, que indicam,
em termos técnicos, a
disponibilidade de um reforço.
Portanto, nas páginas de Alan Kazdin
que lemos para hoje, ele aponta
que se o comportamento que nos
interessa é atender o telefone,
o toque do telefone é um antecedente
que torna o comportamento mais
suscetível a dar origem ao reforço.
O reforço é ser capaz de falar com
alguém do outro lado da linha.
Então, você está em pé na
frente do seu telefone.
Se o telefone toca, há um
motivo para atendê-lo.
Se não toca, não há motivo.
O quadro apresentado pelo
condicionamento operante é uma
forma
de extrair a sugestão aristotélica de
que nós queremos estruturar
as nossas vidas de tal forma que os
comportamentos que queremos
que se tornem parte de nosso
repertório, tornem-se habituais.
E uma das maneiras mais
eficaz de fazer isso
é estruturar a experiência para que a
coisa que não queremos fazer
seja incompatível com um
comportamento alternativo
que colocamos no seu lugar.
Assim, no contexto dos pais,
por exemplo, Kazdin diz:
"Em vez de pensar no
comportamento da criança
em termos do que você
não quer"... certo?
Eu não quero que ela chore; eu não
quero que os irmãos briguem;
eu não quero que fiquem
acordados até meia-noite...
"Comece a pensar em termos do
comportamento que você quer
e recompensar esse oposto".
Então, em vez de dizer para si mesmo:
"Eu não quero passar a noite
conversando com meu amigo e acabar
tendo de ficar acordado a noite
toda", diga: "Qual é o comportamento que
eu desejo cultivar e reforçar?
Qual é a alternativa que impedirá a
minha atuação nos caminhos
que eu não quero e me incentivar a
agir do modo que eu quero?".
Ao fazer isso, você abre para si
mesmo a forma mais profunda
e duradoura do autocontrole humano.
A forma de autocontrole humano que
potencializa a diferença
entre o comprometimento da razão
e a distorção do
espírito e do apetite.
Você associa um comportamento que
não foi previamente reforçado
com consequências positivas.
Quando você se livra de
um comportamento
recompensando o seu oposto, os
efeitos são mais fortes
e duram mais tempo do que se você
punir o comportamento indesejado.
A melhor maneira de construir o
comportamento desejado
é a partir da prática reforçada.
Porém, "a melhor maneira de construir
o comportamento desejado é a
partir da prática reforçada"
é algo que provavelmente
vocês já ouviram antes.
Na verdade, vocês já ouviram isso
antes 3 vezes na aula de hoje.
"Nós aprendemos um ofício ao
produzir o mesmo produto
que devemos produzir quando
tivermos aprendido.
Nós nos tornamos
construtores construindo.
harpistas tocando harpa."
O que nós tentamos fazer no
desafio de Aristóteles,
e no seu equivalente contemporâneo,
é estruturar as nossas vidas
de tal forma que possamos pegar os
compromissos normativos
– coisas que são boas ideias – e
transformá-las em descrições
de comportamentos naturais para nós.
Nós as transformamos de serem
boas ideias a serem leis.
E isso fornece, penso eu, uma nova
visão sobre a passagem
com a qual eu fechei a aula anterior.
Aristóteles escreve que "por
abster-se de prazeres
nos tornamos temperados e, em seguida,
encontramos modo mais fácil
abstermo-nos de prazeres".
É similar com a coragem.
"Da mesma forma se enfrentamos
situações alarmantes
tornamo-nos corajosos, e
então nós encontramo-nos
mais facilmente para enfrentar
situações de alarme."
Então isso, eu acho, é um aspecto
inegável da natureza humana.
Mas não é a história completa.
E os 2 ensaios para a próxima aula
trazem uma complicação para a
história contada hoje
e nos pedem para pensar se
isso descreve totalmente
o que é necessário para
realizar o tipo de mudança
que esperamos alcançar.
Estou ansiosa para comentar estes
textos com vocês na quinta-feira.